let's say there's some company a here
and let's think about what its stock
might be doing let's say this is just
over the course of the day let's say
it's stock is just trading right over
here so as we go through the day its
price and naturally changes but then
right over here let's say this is within
the day maybe this is happening at 10:00
a.m. 10:00 a.m. Eastern Time an
announcement comes out an announcement
comes out that be intends intends to
acquire to acquire a at I don't know
let's say that right now a is let's say
that right now a is trading at $5 this
year but a press release comes out that
B intends to acquire a at $10 a share
and let me write this down at $10 per
share so you can imagine and they say
they're going to do it with cash and
we'll talk in future videos about how it
becomes a little bit more involved
they're going to be doing it with their
own shares but they intend to do it with
cash so if they're able to acquire a
everyone who owns a share of company a
will get $10 for it and those shares
will go to Company B Company B will own
company a all of a sudden so what do you
think would happen to the stock of
Company A we know that B intends to buy
it for $10 a share well you can imagine
if everyone thought that this is
definitely going to happen that anyone
who holds the stock is going to get $10
you could imagine that the stock would
just gap up immediately to something
close to $10 a share something close to
$10 a share and then not even trade much
around it because they know what they're
going to get for it so this is if you
knew that this merger or this
acquisition was going to happen the
reality is is that you don't always know
just from this press release that B
definitely will acquire a maybe they
have to get approval from government
bodies to make sure that they aren't
getting a monopoly here maybe they still
have to get the funding from some bank
they still have to get a loan in order
to be able to do this deal so there's
some what maybe something else happens
maybe there's another bidder who wants
to require a and they're willing to pay
more so you don't know exactly
actly what's going to happen in this
situation so you don't know for sure
this is going to happen so what does
normally happen is that instead of going
all the way up it goes someplace in
between so the reality sort of jumping
from five to ten dollars it might jump
from I don't know five to eight dollars
and maybe it trades around here you
might say well why does it trade at
eight dollars and it would trade at
eight dollars so notice if there was a
hundred percent chance it would trade
all the way to ten dollars right because
that's what a stock a would be worth now
cuz B's going to pay that but if it
trades at eight dollars essentially the
market is saying essentially the market
is saying that we're gonna give you
three fifths right from five to eight is
three dollars so it's giving you three
fifths of the total jump that it could
have if it was a hundred percent chance
or another way to say it is that the
market is saying that there is a 60%
there is a 60% chance that this merger
will go through anyone who thinks that
there's more than a 60% chance if they
do this over a bunch of security so that
all the probabilities
kind of work out eventually they should
buy this security because they could by
date and they think there's a it really
should be worth ten anything whoo anyone
who thinks that no way that this this
acquisition is going to happen that they
be isn't going to get the financing
where the regulatory authorities aren't
going to allow B to do this then they
should short the stock when it goes up
here because if the acquisition falls
through then the stock is going to go
back down here it's gonna go back down
to the five dollar range before the
announcement and so people and
especially hedge funds who act in this
way based on they are thinking that the
merger is more likely to occur or less
likely occur based on their research or
maybe they have some quantitative models
or maybe they have some information
other people don't have that might be
legal or might be otherwise they would
place these bets the people who think
that the merger will happen will by
expecting it to go to ten dollars the
people who think it won't they will
short expecting it to go to five dollars
and this strategy of playing the
probabilities of a merger happening this
is called merger arbitrage merger ARB
sometimes called for short merger
arbitrage
it's Arbor
because someone who who feels like they
know the merger is going to happen they
can buy something for eight and then
sell or they could buy something for
eight that is going to be worth ten
dollars they can sell it for ten at some
future date when B acquires the company
or if they know the merger isn't going
to happen they can short it for eight
and then buy it back for five dollars
once again make kind of doing an
arbitrage on on a price differential
they think something that's worth five
is trading at eight on the downside and
on the upside they think something
that's trading at eight is worth ten